ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
今人身事故があったのかもしれません
日本では毎年3万人弱の方が自ら日の地方としています
都道府県別ではワースト3が秋田県島根県
新潟県と日本海が沿いの鍵がを占めています
最も自殺率が低かったのは大阪府です
お笑いが浸透している町だからかもしれません
そしてここ福岡県はワースト35位
比較的少ない方です
世界では
年間80万人以上の方が自ら命を絶っています
これは
40秒ごとに1人の方が自ら命を絶っているということになります
なぜ
どうしてこれだけ沢山の方々が自ら命を絶ってしまうのか
日本ではこの始発の
いちばんの理由が
健康の問題です
健康の問題にも様々あります
その様々な様々ななかでも最も多いのが
うつ病です
うつ病
最近よく耳にする言葉です
世界中で
3個5000万人の方がながら
うつ病で苦しんでいます
この数字は私が妄想で見たとか夢で見た数字と呼ぶことではなく
世界保健機関 who が発表している数字です
そしてここ日本では1000万人以上の方がうつ病で苦しんでいます
これは
10人に1人という割合になります
ということはですねー
この会場にも
18人の方は
内郷で苦しんでいらっしゃる方がいる
かもしれません
この世界中に問題になっているうつ病
この対策法は何があるのか
今のところ世界中大体どこも同じです
私たちの生活の多くは薬に頼っています
風邪をひいたら薬
お腹が痛いときも区3
どこが退場がおかしいときにも薬
薬くすり薬
ここでは薬が体にどう作用するかというお話ではなく
うつ病にはのも薬以外に特効薬がありますということをお伝えしに行きました
これは三日月です
しかし
三日月という月は存在しません
光の当たり方によってそう見えているだけです
人間の目からそう見えている
認識の世界の話です
お月様はいつも満々です
私たちがどう夫婦もいつもまん丸です
これは
人間関係にも同じことが言えます
あいつは何度言ったらわかるんだ
こいつはなんとこれがわからないんだ
自分はなんてダメなヤツなんだ
人や自分を三日月に捉えて欠けている部分を責める
人間は三日月じゃないんです
お月様と同じまん丸なんです
もともと完全完璧な存在として生まれてきているんです
この完全完璧
これを
どうかこれはどういうことなのか
自分をこのお月様になぞられて見てみます
この自分の
かゲー
見えていないところ
ここに光をあてて
普段見えていないものを見ていきます
自分の能力
自分の個性
自分の素晴らしさ
たくさんあります
ただ普段は暗くて見えていないだけ
見ようとしていないだけです
でも確かにあります
その自分の個性素晴らしい所が沢山集まって
自分という存在があります
完全完璧なまんまるです
じゃあ自分は
自分の事を三日月としてしか捉えられない
その心どういう風にしてこのまんまでの心がまんま自分はまん丸なんだという風に
持っていけるのか
具体的にどうすればそういうことができるのか
それが
うつ病の特効薬になります
この
満月のような白い紙を1枚
用意します
そこに
自分の名前を書きます
そして
自分の素晴らしいところ
一つ一つ
思い出して書いていきます
例えば
文を優しい
成立が
人の痛みが分かる
物腰が柔らかい
争うことが嫌い
なんでもけっこうです一つ一つ思い出して書いていきます
必ず出てきますから
そして
人間関係がうまくいかない
辛い苦しいという方は
もう一枚
白い紙を用意します
そして
そこに相手の方の名前を書きます
それからその方の素晴らしいところ
一つ一つ
見つけて書いていきます
例えばその方は自分に厳しい
努力家である
自信がある
意志が強い
行動力がある
なんでもけっこうです
一つ一つ思い出して見つけて書いていきます
以上です
えっ
それだけって
思われた方もいらっしゃると思いますが
範囲
それだけです
人間の心は同時に2つのことが考えられません
あの人は素晴らしい一だーって思ったらもう心もそちらのほうに流れていきます
これを心の傾向性といいます
今までの
あいつはダメだ自分はダメだと言う三日月にしか捉えられない
その心がこのまん丸の心に変わる
そうするとどうなんか
うつ病の原因をつくっていた心三日月の心がまん丸の心に変わります
そうするとうつ病の原因が変わるわけですから
うつ病は自然に消えてなくなります
これが欝病の特効薬です
特効薬は
近くのコンビニはドラッグストアには売ってません
お医者さんに処方していただくものでもありません
どこかにマザーが出かけて手に入れる必要もありません
もともと自分の中にある特効薬です
お金もかかりません
0円です
この満月まん丸のお月様と同じ
丸0円です
白い紙を1万用意してそこにただ書いていくだけです
たったこれだけ
世界中で大きな社会問題になっている
うつ病の特効薬になります
たったそれだけでと笑っちゃうっていう風に思われる方もいらっしゃるかもしれない
ですか
私は笑われても嬉しいです
笑うということは
それだけ明るくなるじゃないですか
本日のケットのテーマ believe です
信じてください
是非試してみてください
そうすると自分が完全完璧なまんまる
素晴らしい満月だったんだということが見えてくるでしょう
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]